[Music]
Hello, how are you? Natalia Lancelot greets you
and with your brief informative for today,
Friday, October 22, the metropolitan police are
investigating a shooting on the
outskirts of Mire with Myles shops,
immediately after the plan in Hollywood, this
occurred around 3 in the morning.
detectives say it happened outside on
the sidewalk of the mall
when officers arrived at the scene they
found a man with a gunshot wound
he is expected to recover this story is
still developing if you are looking for a
job i have good news for you good
will will be offering a  job fair
today to hire
full and part timers this event will be at
the branch located on eastern
near hwy 215 starts
at 9am good luck and the
las vegas dances are coming home this
sunday to take on  the sons of
philadelphia the interim coach rich
pizzas will already go for his second game
after the resignation of weber the first one
won it  against the denver broncos
we will see if he will have the same luck
this Sunday starting at one in the
afternoon and now we turn to the
weather forecast we will have a sunny sky with
temperatures reaching 82 degrees
for the afternoon we will stay in the
seventies for the rest  of the week there is
a slight chance of drizzle
for Monday have a nice
weekend Natalia Lanzelotti greets you and
this was your brief informative of and we
now Spanish
[Music]